hello i'm johnny knoxville and today i'm
going to be breaking down some of the
biggest moments in jackass history
[Music]
i'm johnny knoxville and i'm
butterbaiting today we're gonna do a
little boxing
i love boxing and i love knockouts so
the butterbean fight was right up my
alley touch gloves and come out fighting
i remember when he showed up that
morning i said butterbean i need you to
go full speed today he goes johnny i
can't do that i said butterbean i need
you to go full speed he goes you don't
got to beg me and i was like oh
maybe i shouldn't have said that but he
went full speed all day long he was so
fun and jovial and then susie put on the
boxing gloves i said something to him
like hey buddy
and he looked at me like he didn't
recognize me and then my knees started
shaking
oh
in the footage you can see me snoring
but my doctor told me that's you just
trying to swallow your tongue and i knew
i had to try and make it funny because
it could be borderline dark in those
situations so i luckily had enough
wherewithal to come up with the line is
butter being okay
is butter being okay
because i thought i'd kill them
i got my entry into doing stunts by
doing a participatory journalism article
for big brother magazine which jeff
tremaine was the editor of that magazine
and a lot of the guys in jackass came
from big brother and my idea for the
article was to test
pepper spray
stun gun taser gun and then shoot myself
while wearing a bulletproof vest with a
38 revolver
i had to buy the cheapest vest they had
at the time because i didn't have any
money but luckily it worked
and so it was a natural pathway into
doing a riot what is it right grenade
control test
yeah and it was a stingmore mine which
shot out thousands of little hard rubber
balls
initially after we did the test
in front of the cast no one was going to
do it except for me i was sitting in the
car listening to my cousin roger alan
wade's music
and ryan gets in the car and he's like
sorry man
i'm not i'm just not going to do it i
don't feel like doing this and i'm like
it's okay buddy you don't have to do it
and then they called me into the set and
he just gets out of the car with me
and just starts walking in stride with
me
by then i could tell he was going to do
it and then bam was telling us no way is
he going to do it but i remember
convincing him with look it's just loud
it's just loud it's loud it's going to
hurt really bad but it's just loud it's
going to hurt but it's just loud which
was not a very good way of convincing
him but somehow that worked and bam
ended up doing it and he was gold
because i think he cried
ah
are you crying i think he's hurt out of
the original self-defense test the
pepper spray was the most painful
because it just is someone started a
fire in your eyes and feels like they're
putting it out with gasoline it's like
15 or 20 minutes of intense pain
and then you get home later that night
take a shower and you reactivate it the
water reactivates it so you're blind
again that's a terrible pain and the
riot control test that hurt but also i
had vertigo at the time so when i went
down the room starts spinning
right control test stung you know i
think what scared the guys most
it was extremely loud
extremely loud
the hard rubber balls stung
but i don't know
thank god i covered my face and my nuts
because
my hands the next day looked like a
leopard because that's where most of the
things hit in my face and on my nuts
but it worked out
now i'm lubing up
i can't see the car the little toy car
because i'm going to put it in my butt
[Laughter]
that one is one of the casts favorite
bits ever maybe it's the number one it
was written for stevo but his father
said no yeah and
ryan dunn was like this is too good of
an idea for someone not to shoot it
oh [ __ ] it i'll do it because he would
always step in a lot and take one for
the team and it ended up he was the
perfect person for it he was so funny
and then the doctor we found
like by a miracle the doctor we found
was perfect
he was like concerned for
ryan like confused disgusted the doctor
had all these emotions and you really
feel that as you're watching it
[Music]
talk to anybody we have a girlfriend
and the radiologist when she took the
x-ray out of the machine that look on
her face
and and the x-ray was
it's like someone a photographer shot is
like a graphic designer it was like it's
nothing but a toy car up someone's ass
everything about that we lucked into it
was perfect
what's your name again what
irving yeah irving zissman
spike had used tony gardner to dress up
some of his skaters
like eric costa and those guys as old
men
and he suggested that
i dress up as an old man and do pranks
so i got to give that nod to spike as
far as the character it's kind of a more
intense version of myself and a little
bit of my father irving's kind of a
pervert
all right kid it's time for grandpa's
massaging
get massages with happy endings that's
right
say goodbye to the hippies bye hippies
i've been in instances where people have
wanted to beat irene up before luckily
no one's swung on me yet but they've
definitely wanted to beat irene up
before but i'm usually pretty good at
winding people up and when they get
their angriest i can wind them down a
little calm them down and then wind them
back up just step over that line
oh you stepped over the line
that's one of my few skills that i have
prick skills
hello i'm johnny knoxville and i'm about
to rent a car you know when we're doing
a prank we always clear it with the
owner of the company so we know that
they'll sign off so the owner knew but
the employee doesn't know and if we
figure out they might recognize us we
won't air it but in this case the
employee had no clue when i rented the
car from him and when i returned it it
was the same guy and he was not very
happy with me i had a
accident as you can see yeah i i mean i
drink i just black out so like
um were you drinking or anything
yeah i had a little we filmed that in
portland oregon as opposed to portland
texas
and the crush of derby turned out to be
pretty gnarly i got a car that drove
right up the hood and almost
into my face
which wouldn't have been so bad the
prank has a stunt aspect to it as well
some pranks do and some pranks don't but
that one that one had it all we're gonna
have to get this worked out
yeah you're gonna have to pay for that
car
well you're gonna have to help me pay
for that car no we don't do that i
returned it with the
full of my tank of gas
you return it
demolished the biggest obstacle is to
get coverage on the guy you're pranking
i think i had to wear a helmet cam to
get that coverage because we're inside
his business and you can't plant a bunch
of cameras inside his business they're
going to see that
you know even if you put camera hides up
they're going to
know that something's that wasn't there
yesterday
so
that was the biggest concern and i think
all the coverage of him was through my
helmet cam
hello i'm johnny knoxville and this is
the anaconda ball pit
oh well manny you know when we deal with
alligators he's our safety guy steve oh
is shooting a bit with alligators and at
the safety meeting he's like okay when
we're filming this today if the
alligator does bite stevo hopefully he
will let go
and that was his whole plan for the for
if stevo gets bit
so you know mandy's incredibly strong
and he would jump in and help but when
you're working with animals like an
alligator or an anaconda there's only so
much you can do and it kind of bit me
several times
after the bit we filmed you're like yeah
that anaconda bit someone's calf off
last week like thank god you told me
that afterwards i remember i'm like okay
i don't want the anaconda to bite my
wrists that was my irrational fear
because if he bites my wrist that's
going to be trouble
so my solution to that was i put a strip
of electrical tape around each wrist
which would have done
nothing right it would have done nothing
but in my mind i was protected
there was two in there and the one was
really quiet didn't move around much but
uh yeah that second one was dangerous
oh my god we forgot about the other
snake
this is the toro todder it's me and
pontius versus dunn and bam
and the last man on the teeter-totter is
the winner we were shooting at gary
lefu's ranch he's who we use when we
deal with bulls he's been amazing and
got us incredible footage and kept us
somehow from getting forever
injured we were shooting
an idea at his ranch that day that i'd
saw on tom and jerry where tom puts on
the blindfold and puts in a cigarette in
a bowl smokes him
so we did that with a yak
and since we were there gary's like hey
why don't you do the toro todder idea
and we're like what's that and i said
you know you get a
teeter-totter and put in the middle of a
bull ring and we're like that sounds
great so that was gary's idea and thank
goodness because it turned out
wonderfully
[Music]
see bulls just hate movement they don't
care about color they want to kill
anything that moves if you're in a
boring and you stand completely still
like odds on they're probably not going
to hit you
but one bull came out and as the toro
toddler was moving hit the toro toddler
i get a lot of my ideas if not directly
from a cartoon but thinking that life's
a cartoon like the giant hand in
jackass 3d
is very cartoony and i thought that
would be funny no one really had faith
in that idea but we know enough that
okay that may not work but let's try it
anyway and luckily it worked i love
shooting things inspired by a cartoon
my name is johnny knoxville and this is
the high five
we asked the crew members to be bringing
in some food at the same time
aaron was so it didn't look so out of
the blue like can you carry soup in it's
like okay we'll have people out there
carrying food in and they'll ask aaron
to carry some soup in
what up aaron what's up dude yeah dude
how about this crowd brother
like i don't think we got anyone else to
carry the soup
but uh thank god he did
but yeah we have crew members help out
with pranks too you know we had our
costume designer emily ting like she was
dressing the guys and while they're in
there getting dressed they walked up
hard steps but
when they walked out it was like balsa
wood steps she knew what was going on
and she played along but the crew
members
everybody's in on it right
the whole set is working to get the guys
hi i'm johnny knoxville and this is my
big red rocket five four three two
one go
that was uh jackass number two and i was
in a real
mindset then so
i don't remember being terrified i just
remember being
ecstatic that we just got that footage
but it was a pretty crazy moment because
a foot long metal rod shot out not only
this close to my ribs but one goes 300
yards back and splits two of our art
department guys right between their ears
scott manning and mike kasich and that
would have decapitated them
so a lot of people got lucky on set that
day
i forget whose idea that was but we
don't do research ahead of time it's
just like let's see what happens if we
stand behind a jet engine and get things
launched at us we'd rather rehearse on
film because that's what's funny you
don't want to rehearse ahead of time
that that destroys jackass you know
we're scientists at the end of the day
so we're gathering data on what would
happen if you stood behind a jet and had
footballs or
tomatoes or whatever thrown at you or
jump off a thing with an umbrella
that really our friend louis fall up he
just powdered his collarbone it picked
him up for a while
that was maybe one of our first days of
filming we were filming with 3d so it
was like we had this whole 3d crew on
the set and ponte is usually just
carrying an ax or a knife on him or
something aaron had annoyed pontius and
pontius had his knife out and was trying
to stab aaron i just go over to jeff
who's behind the 3d you know he's
looking into the 3d monitor he's got his
headphones on i'm like jeff will you go
get pontius because he's trying to stab
aaron
jeff
he takes off his headphones
okay pontius come on give me your knife
give me your knife
and finally ponty is like okay and gives
him his knife he tried to stab him again
later in the movie when we're doing the
lamborghini tooth pull relax
oh
oh aaron said something annoyed pontius
and he just got out his knife and was
like slashing his
throat
and i had to get the knife from him
the boys are a real handful sometimes
i'm steve o and this is the pooh
cocktail supreme they said we weren't
allowed to put human feces in there so
we found a company that sells dog feces
and put that in there but a few crew
members did put real feces in there
[Music]
all our stuff is janky right
so we hope he doesn't launch into space
but uh luckily he didn't but speaking of
space the poop did go weightless
for a while we weren't expecting that
and stevo had goggles on and all these
things but he forgot to keep his mouth
shut thank goodness
it was raining
on all of the crew yeah no one thought
of that
no one thought of that everyone got it
it was a disgusting set and then you
know the hug's coming as soon as stevo
gets let out a hug's coming
yeah you gotta be on your toes
two
one
that one when i was inside the cannon
which is like
you can't there's no space
there's no [ __ ] space inside the
cannon i was just trying to focus on
spreading my wings when i come out
spreading my wings when i come out i
knew that was the shot and i didn't know
how it's going to come out if i was
going to be flipping or what so that's
all i wanted to do and thank goodness i
did it i hit the water with such force
if i would have went in flat back i
would have broke my back my ass absorbed
100 of the impact and i couldn't sit
down for like two weeks
two or three weeks it was just
incredibly painful to sit and that was
just one take
one tank
you know i didn't even know if we were
going to do anything with the bull this
movie because we've done it all in the
past i'm like maybe we won't do the
bulls this movie
but i wanted to prank an animal
and trick an animal so we like okay well
a magic trick on an animal
and then it just naturally became a bowl
because trying to trick a bull is going
to get you really good footage and boy
did it in the movie that's the second
time i did it
i did a take before and the bull didn't
come at me for the first like 90 seconds
and when he finally hit me he just
smoked me in the ribs and put me out
like a cigarette into the ground and it
was one of those things that really hurt
but it didn't look amazing
which sucks to get hit by a bull and
have it not go in the movie
so
like i knew it jeff knew it everybody
knew that we had to go again and then
they changed bulls and they put pecker
wrecker in there that's the bull's name
and he did the job that was a broken
wrist broken rib concussion and a brain
hemorrhage i spent the weekend in the
hospital
and it took me a few months to recover
from that my brain was scrambled
all right everybody thank you for
watching please see jackass forever in
theaters now woohoo
[Music]